منذ بدايه الحرب قبل نحوي عام تعرضت شبه
جزيره القرم لسلسله هجمات بطائرات مسيره
كانت جميعها تستهدف الاسطول البحريه
الروسيه
على البحر الاسود وفي الحديث والثلاثين من
يوليو 2020 اعلى السلطات المواليه لروسيا
في القرب اصابه خمسه اشخاص جراه هجوم
بطائره مسيره على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
بعد اقل من شهر وتحديدا في الثامن عشر من
اغسطس 2022 اعلن حاكم مدينه سيفاسبل ان
الدفاعات الجويه في شبه جزيره القرم اسقطت
طائره مسيره قرب مطار بيلبك شمالي شمالي
غربيه المدينه دون وقوعه خسائر الهجوم
الاكبر كان في التاسع والعشرين من اكتوبر
الماضي حين هاجمت 16 طائره مسيره اسطولا
البحر الاسود الروسي في صف سبل وعلى اثر
الهجوم وعلقت موسكو مؤقتا مشاركتها في
اتفاق تصدير انبوبه بعد اقل من شهر وفي
الثاني والعشرين من نوفمبر الماضي اعلنت
السلطات المواليه لموسكو اسقاط 5 طائرات
مسيره في سماء القرن قالت انها حاولت
استهداف محطه بكلافا الحراريه لتوليد
الكهرباء